hagamos otro problema de razones que ya
es prácticamente un clásico supongamos
que inicialmente tengo cierta cantidad
de fruta así es que tengo cierta
cantidad de fruta regresaré a eso en un
momento pero sabemos que la razón
la razón
d
manzanas y voy a poner manzanas en rojo
la razón de manzanas y naranjas naranjas
lo pongo en anaranjado se parecen un
poco estos colores sabemos que la razón
de manzanas a naranjas es de 5 a 8 es de
5 a 8 también se escribe como 5 a 8 así
tal cual es la razón de manzanas
naranjas ahora lo que también sé de este
problema es que cuando eliminó 15
manzanas así es que
eliminó
elimino
15 manzanas 15 manzanas
la razón la razón resulta 1 a 4
la razón de manzanas a naranjas resulta
en 1 a 4
cuántas
manzanas
cuántas no mejor cuántas en total
cuantas déjame escribirlo así mejor
cuántas
frutas
en total
tengo
tengo después
de
eliminar después de eliminar las 15
manzanas así es que después de eliminar
las 15 manzanas cuántas frutas en total
me quedan hagamos un poco de álgebra
digamos
x
digamos que x es el número de frutas el
número de frutas al inicio el número de
frutas que teníamos inicialmente cuánta
fruta nos va a quedar al final si
quitamos 15 manzanas no estamos haciendo
nada a las naranjas x menos 30 lo voy a
hacer en un color distinto x menos 30 no
x menos 15 x menos 15 esto va a ser el
número de frutas que tenemos al final el
número de frutas que tenemos al final
sabemos que estas 2 se cumplen sabemos
también que la razón de manzanas a
naranjas con la que empezamos es de 5 a
8 la razón inicial de manzanas a
naranjas es de 5 a 8 y esto qué quiere
decir bueno quiere decir que si nosotros
hacemos grupos con nuestra fruta siempre
vamos a tener una relación de 5 manzanas
a 8 naranjas o si ponemos números
precisos
los grupos de 13 frutas por
cada
grupo por cada grupo de
frutas
por cada grupo de 13 frutas vamos a
tener ahí
manzanas hay 5 manzanas
naranjas por cada grupo de 13 frutas hay
5 manzanas y 8 naranjas y cuántos grupos
de 13 frutas hay bien si x es el número
total de frutas entonces si dividimos x
entre 13 si dividimos el número total de
frutas entre 13 este de aquí es el 13
este es el 13 entonces si estoy diciendo
el número total de frutas entre 13 lo
que estoy obteniendo con esta cantidad
de x entre 13 el número de grupos de 13
frutas que inicialmente puedo formar
ahora por cada grupo tengo 5 manzanas
cuantas manzanas tengo inicialmente si
este es el número de grupos que tengo
inicialmente tenía 5 manzanas por cada
grupo inicialmente tengo 5 por x sobre
13 manzanas ahora por cada uno de estos
grupos también tengo 8 naranjas cuántas
naranjas tengo tengo 8 veces eso por
cada grupo de 13 tengo 8 naranjas así es
que tengo 8
x sobre 13 naranjas bien eso es lo que
tenía al inicio al eliminar 15 manzanas
la razón de manzanas a naranjas la razón
de manzanas a naranjas resulta ser 1 a 4
es igual a 1 a 4 lo cual quiere decir
que por cada grupo por cada grupo de 5
sumamos estas dos cantidades 1 y 45 por
cada grupo de 5 frutas hay
por cada grupo de 5 frutas hay una
manzana
una manzana y cuatro
naranjas y cuatro naranjas muy bien
entonces cuántos grupos de cinco frutas
tenemos bien esta es la cantidad de
fruta que nos queda ya que quitamos 15
manzanas así es que cuántos grupos de 5
tenemos tomamos la cantidad de fruta que
nos queda x menos 15 y la dividimos
entre 5 que es el tamaño de cada grupo
así es que esto nos va a dar esto es
igual al número de grupos de cinco
frutas grupos de cinco frutas ahora en
cada uno de estos grupos voy a tener una
manzana y cuatro naranjas así es que
cuantas manzanas y cuántas naranjas me
quedan una vez que he quitado 15
manzanas
pensemos cuantas manzanas voy a tener
tengo una manzana en cada uno de estos
grupos así es que el número de grupos es
el número de manzanas así es que son x
menos 15 sobre 5 manzanas y cuántas
naranjas voy a tener en cada uno de
estos grupos
voy a tener 4 naranjas
que multiplicando 4 por el número de
grupos lo cual puede escribir como
cuatro quintos por equis 15 esto nos va
a dar el número de naranjas naranjas de
acuerdo cuatro veces el número de grupos
de cinco frutas bien que es lo que no
cambia altere el número de manzanas pero
no afecte el número de naranjas así es
que este número el número de naranjas
que tenemos al inicio es igual a este
número el número de naranjas que tenemos
al final hay muchas maneras de atacar
este problema pero esta fue la que se me
ocurrió como la más directa encontremos
entonces el valor de x estas dos
cantidades tienen que ser iguales nunca
cambian esto lo podemos escribir
matemáticamente como 8 x sobre 13 es
igual
cuatro quintos cuatro quintos que
multiplica a x 15 y aquí quizá lo mejor
que podemos hacer es multiplicar todo
por cinco cuartos multiplicamos entonces
por cinco cuartos el lado izquierdo y
multiplicamos por cinco cuartos el lado
derecho estos términos se cancelan el
coeficiente se hace 1 y del lado
izquierdo que obtenemos 4 entre 4 es 18
entre 4 es 2 así que nos queda 5 por 2
10 x sobre 13 10 x sobre 13 que es igual
a x menos 15 ahora restamos x a ambos
lados de la ecuación
así es que la ecuación resulta 10 x
sobre 13 menos x es igual a menos 15
vamos a bajarnos un poco vamos a hacer
la resta de 10 x sobre 13 menos x le
escribimos el lado izquierdo como 10 x
sobre 13 menos 13 x sobre 13 lo cual es
igual a menos 15 10 x sobre 13 menos 13
x sobre 13 es igual a menos 3 x sobre 13
lo cual sigue siendo igual a menos 15 y
ahora multiplicamos por menos 13 tercios
multiplicamos por menos 13 tercios del
lado izquierdo y multiplicamos por menos
13 tercios del lado derecho y
multiplique por menos 13 tercios para
cancelar los 13 y los 3 aquí estos
signos menos se hacen más y nos queda el
lado izquierdo tan solo x y del lado
derecho que nos queda este menos y este
menos si hacen más este 15 y este 13
pueden evidente 3 15 entre 13 5 3 entre
3 es igual a 1 y me queda tan solo 5 por
13 este más de aquí era para indicar que
se transformaban en positivo el producto
de dos signos negativos así es que 5 por
13 cuánto es 5 por 12 es 60 5 por 13 es
65 pero esa no es la solución
recordemos que establecimos que x es el
número de frutas al inicio que acabamos
de calcular es igual a 65 pero la
pregunta que nos hicieron la pregunta
que nos hacen es
cuánta fruta tengo después de eliminar
15 manzanas así es que nos piden el
valor de x 15 después de que eliminamos
15 manzanas la cantidad de fruta que nos
queda es x menos 15 65 menos 15 son 50
nos quedan 50 50 manzanas no no son 50
manzanas más bien son 50 piezas de fruta
nos quedan 50 piezas de fruta es lo que
nos preguntan si quieres puedes checar
cuantas manzanas tenía al inicio cuantas
después que elimine 15 cuántas naranjas
había y todo lo demás pero lo que nos
están preguntando es cuántas frutas en
total tengo después de eliminar las 15
manzanas